arnaud montebourg il a lancé sa campagne
avec la remonte à dar l'idée c'était de
redynamiser réindustrialiser la france
remonte bouhriz et la france et puis
patatras voilà qu'il a parlé du
transfert d'argent des travailleurs
immigrés vers les pays africains avec
western union entre autres en disant
qu'il fallait empêcher ces transferts
attaquer les pays et les empêcher
résultat c'est la débandade à la
dégringolade a quasiment là fini ta dah
de la campagne les jeunes avec
montebourg qui était oui il y en avait
quelques-uns ont fermé le compte twitter
lancé à communiqué de presse en disant
on arrête alors de nouveaux jeunes avec
montebourg sont arrivés certains
supports de la gauche républicaine et
socialistes nous ont dit on arrête la
campagne avec arnaud montebourg il s'est
rendu compte évidemment de la bourde
énorme qui l'avait fait pour lui en tant
que candidat de gauche de sortir un truc
pareil le mal est fait j'ai l'impression
qu'il aura du mal à rattraper les wagons
la campagne de montebourg me semble
difficilement sauvadet
[Musique]